a talented and gallant lady who packed
up the Oscar she won and moved off the
Peyton Place is back here this evening
to present the next award Miss Dorothy
Malone
in the magic shops known as studio
special effects departments there's no
such word as impossible anything can be
done and from all the wizard who
committed this year to film the Academy
is nominated for the best achievements
in visual effects two films the greatest
story ever told George Stevens
production the United Artists special
visual effects by Jay Macmillan Johnson
and Thunderball and Albert broccoli
Harry Saltzman production United Artists
special visual effects by John steers
they have the animal piece the winner is
John steers for Thunderball
on behalf of mr. John steers Ivan tour
thank you I accept the award for John's
tears with gratitude in his name I would
like to thank those who had assisted him
especially Jordan Klein the underwater
engineer and the underwater team Bobby
bacala and her husband for giving them
such a fine opportunity to do the
fantastic thank you very much